et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
adrien de 4 ans bonjour bon j'aime
beaucoup d'être avec nous député du nord
coordinateur de la france insoumise on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est alors stéphane bonjour
qui dirige le bureau parisien du journal
ouest france on commence avec
l'actualité actualité du jour qui est
marquée par la remise du rapport sauvé
du nom de jean marc sauvé qui préside la
commission indépendante sur les abus
sexuels commis au sein de l'église on
connaît déjà des premiers chiffres près
de trois mille prêtres qui ont été
pédophiles depuis les années 50 plus de
cent mille victimes depuis les années 50
il était nécessaire de faire ce travail
et de le rendre public c'était
indispensable pour vous évidemment on a
eu beaucoup d'affaires qui ont éclaté au
compte-gouttes ces dernières années ces
dernières décennies je crois que là on a
un rapport qui montre l'ampleur de la
situation
l'ampleur aussi du nombre de victimes à
qui il faut pouvoir donner réparation et
ensuite créer des conditions avec les
cultes que cela ne se reproduise plus
parce que c'est intolérable et parce
qu'on voit que quand on en arrive à un
nombre de cas on parle du chiffre de
cent mille victimes potentielles pour
trois mille 3000 est accusé on voit bien
que là on n'a pas affaire à quelque
chose qui est qui est autre chose que
systémique c'est très important
donc oui ce rapport je crois et est
salutaire et puis moi j'adresse d'abord
un mot de compassion à toutes les
victimes à leurs familles parce que je
sais que parfois y compris des années
après ce type d'actualité vient rouvrir
des cicatrices qui n'était pas à
pleinement refermer
comment on fait pour que cela ne se
reproduise plus je reprends le terme une
quarantaine de préconisations qui
accompagne ce rapport qu est-ce que quel
est le regard que vous portez sur ceux
sur cette image est pas encore lu la
totalité du rapport et ses
préconisations mais je crois qu'il faut
incontestablement des moyens
supplémentaires et compris en termes de
formation d'accompagnement et puis
de recueil de la parole des victimes
c'est vrai que on a eu un grand
mouvement de libération de la parole sur
les agressions sexuelles ces dernières
années et on voit qu'on a encore des
carences pour accueillir cette parole
est ensuite faire en sorte d'accompagner
les personnes ont la parole se libère
vers la justice donc je pense que c'est
là qu'il faut faire l'essentiel comme
d'ailleurs depuis le début de ce
quinquennat sur un autre registre sur
les violences sexuelles et sexistes les
féminicides également nous demandons à
ce que le gouvernement mette sur la
table les moyens qui correspondent aux
ambitions qu'il a affichée on nous a dit
par exemple les violences sexistes
sexuel ce sera la grande cause du
quinquennat on voit que certains pays
c'est le cas de l'espagne par exemple
pour me 1 milliards sur la table ça fait
depuis le début du quinquennat comment
donc ces moyens supplémentaires soient
soient posés ça veut dire que sur cette
question des abus sexuels au sein de
l'église pour vous il n'ya pas que
l'église qui dans ta main travail le
gouvernement au sida doit prendre des
mesures évidemment je pense qu'il faut
pouvoir mettre en corrélation les
ambitions affichées avec les actes posés
l'autre sujet d'actualité aujourd'hui
c'est cette mobilisation syndicale dans
plusieurs villes de france à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats pour demander une
hausse des salaires une augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat et hier le gouvernement
vous l'avez sans doute dû à publier un
bilan de son quinquennat en matière de
pouvoir d'achat il quitte le pouvoir
d'achat augmenter augmentation du revenu
disponible global c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement de 8 % en cinq ans
progression bien supérieure au
quinquennat précédent d assécher la
belle affaire non la réalité c'est que
vous avez aujourd'hui six français sur
dix estiment que pendant le quinquennat
macron ils ont perdu du pouvoir d'achat
alors le gouvernement on peut essayer à
l'entonnoir
le gouvernement dès maintenant les
chiffres sont là où tu es moi je vous
parle pas de ressenti quand je vous dis
que un français sur trois a du mal à
payer son loyer qu'un français sur cinq
dit devoir sauter un repas pour pouvoir
boucler ses fins de mois que 8 millions
de français ont besoin de l'aide
alimentaire que 2 millions y ont recours
dont un million seulement depuis l'année
dernière qu'à l'heure où je vous parle
en sait encore pas plus tard qu'hier
soir on a vu ces files d'attentes devant
les chefs des banques alimentaires de la
part de beaucoup de jeunes donc si vous
voulez le quinquennat de monsieur macron
a été en quinquennat ou comme nous
l'avions dit dès le début beaucoup a été
fait pour les plus riches prenez cet
exemple les 500 familles les plus riches
de ce pays possédait 570 milliards de
patrimoine au début du quinquennat de
monsieur macron ce patrimoine a doublé
pour les plus riches bruno le maire il
dit qu'un travailleur au smic avec son
revenu augmenter de 60 70 euros d'un
mois depuis le début du gala les
dernières mesures gouvernementales et
dire aux travailleurs aux semi fléchie
mais écoutez dès l'instant où fait des
démonstrations de quelques petites
augmentations par des primes par des
choses comme ça avec par ailleurs les
factures augmentent comme elles ont
augmenté non ce quinquennat n'a pas été
un quinquennat d'augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat et d'ailleurs c'est pas de mon
fait si six français sur dix se disent
non de mon pouvoir d'achat n'a pas
augmenté je disais que donc les 500
familles les plus riches ont doublé leur
patrimoine mais dans le même temps dans
le même temps sur la même période vous
avez près de 3 millions de pauvres en
plus donc la question du partage des
richesses se pose évidemment il y à une
urgence sociale dans ce pays or le
gouvernement n'entend pas y répondre
autrement que par une forme de
continuité et la manifestation qu'il ya
aujourd'hui sur la réforme de
l'assurance chômage moi j'appelle toutes
celles et ceux qu'ils m'entendent à y
participer parce que cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage loin de finalement
lutter contre le chômage fait la chasse
aux chômeurs avec des indemnités qui
vont baisser de manière considérable
pour un simple changement du mode de
calcul on estime que avec cette réforme
qui entre en vigueur le 1er octobre vous
avez plus d'un million de personnes qui
vont voir leurs indemnités chômage
baisser en moyenne de 17% mais il faut
rappeler que le chômage ça n'est pas la
charité quand vous êtes au chômage c'est
parce que vous avez cotisé pour une
assurance pour un risque en quelque
sorte et le gouvernement plastronne sur
une reprise économique qui serait
absolument formidable dit que le
problème de l'emploi finalement ce
serait des emplois non pourvus et le
chômage volontaire pardon mais quand
vous prenez un peu de recul sur la
situation aujourd'hui on estime que les
emplois non pourvus qu'ils sont une
réalité que je ne conteste pas c'est à
peu près 260 4000 emplois non pourvus si
vous mettez ça en corrélation avec le
nombre de personnes inscrites à pôle
emploi ça vous fait en emplois non
pourvus pour à peu près 24 chômeurs
disponibles donc le problème n'est pas
le chômage volontaire qui est un
véritable fantasme parce que le chômage
est d'abord une souffrance il faut le
rappeler c'est le manque de création
d'emplois pérennes on a quand même vu
dans la période récente un effort énorme
en tout cas une très grosse dépense
d'argent public pour permettre de
sauvegarder les emplois de maintenir les
gens en activité malgré le mal gréco
vide est-ce que ça fallait pas le faire
parce que c'est aussi une forme de
maintien du 2d de défense du pouvoir
d'achat est ce que ça ça fait partie des
choses qui n'auraient pas été
correctement conduite il aurait fallu le
faire avec une stratégie
ciblée en fonction des entreprises que
l'on aidé la politique du gouvernement a
consisté sans stratégie sans
contrepartie à catapulter des milliards
d'argent public sans rien demander en
retour ces métiers-là ils sont parlé
qu'aux riches pour le coup alors ils ont
été ils ont catapulté est mal répartie
mais oui mais justement ils ont été
catapultés mal répartie long terme à des
gens a permis car j'ai vraiment garder
leur emploi ça a permis notamment avec
le chômage partiel d'un effet maintenir
des emplois mais songez que le même
argent public a aussi permis d'en
détruire vous avez des entreprises qui
ont touché cet argent public de l'état
et ce sont finalement fondu dans la
toile de fond de lac au vide pour
procéder à des plans de licenciement
qu'ils avaient déjà prévu auparavant et
donc ils ont touché le pactole ils ont
conjugué l'argent public qu'on leur
verse et avec des plans de licenciement
les résultats c'est qu'avec cet argent
ils ont même détruit des emplois et avec
une capacité qui a continué comment
expliquez-vous que 100 % des entreprises
du cac 40 qui ont bénéficié des aides de
l'état dont certains d'ailleurs
certaines on va en parler après ont des
activités dans les paradis fiscaux en
2021 années de crise elles vont verser
51 milliards de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires ses 140 % de leurs
bénéfices donc ça montre bien que si
vous laissez pas un souci d'intérêt
général ou d'investissements pour
l'avenir vous avez des gens qui ont
profité de la crise il faut le dire
raison pour laquelle les gens qui ont
été beaucoup aidé par le gouvernement
est ce que c'est vrai mais c'est bien
sûr et d'ailleurs j'alerte sur le fait
nous l'avons fait avec jean luc
mélenchon et je profite de l'occasion ce
matin pour leur faire pour dire qu'il
faut reporter l'échéance des
remboursements du prêt garanti par
l'état parce que sinon vous avez
quelques 12 % des entreprises qui vont
avoir un mal de chien à rembourser et
qui peut-être vont se retrouver
véritablement en difficulté en attendant
on ne peut pas tolérer qu'il y ait eu
des profits sur la pandémie ce que nous
avons dit et que jean luc mélenchon
c'est que la situation est une situation
de crise on avait beaucoup de français
qui en ont pâti on en a parlé à
l'instant donc on pourrait faire en
sorte par une taxe exceptionnelle de
procéder à des redistributions voyez par
exemple je sais quoi cet axe est une
sorte de taxe coville c'est à dire c'est
en quelque sorte la considérer qui a été
fait pendant considérer qu'on pourrait
geler les dividendes sur la période de
pandémie selon la bonne vieille règle
pas de profit sur la pandémie regardez
par exemple on parle beaucoup de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie
alors on regarde en réalité quels sont
les chiffres des différents fournisseurs
d'énergie les trois fournisseurs
d'énergie les trois principaux
fournisseurs d'énergie viennent de
réaliser des profits de l'ordre de 13
milliards d'euros si on avait taxé ne
serait ce que 10 % de ses profits 10%
seulement réalisé dans la période on
pourrait distribuer 500 euros à chacun
des trois millions de foyers qui sont en
précarité énergétique qui ont besoin du
gaz pour se chauffer loyer c'est à dire
que la priorité absolue face à l'urgence
sociale c'est de soulager véritablement
les gens les françaises et les français
avec leur revenu voilà pourquoi nous
avons proposé un blocage des prix si
possible un blocage des prix qui
n'intervient pas après la hausse parce
que monsieur castex est venu sur le
plateau du jt pour dire en substance aux
français demain les factures augmentent
après demain je bloque les prix très
bien mais les français viennent de subir
la hausse du mois d'octobre celle du
mois de septembre celle du mois d'août
celle du mois de juillet qu'une
éventuelle et une éventuelle nouvelle
hausse est ce que ça quand même c'est
pas déjà bien mais évidemment ou de ce
point de vue on peut considérer que
c'est une petite victoire pour nous
parce que ça fait maintenant trois
semaines que jean luc mélenchon réclame
qu'on bloque les prix mais monsieur
monsieur castex aurait pu aussi trouvé
l'occasion par une solution comme celle
que je viens de proposer de
véritablement amortir le choc parce que
les français aujourd'hui ces hausses de
gaz ils les ont subies et donc en
quelque sorte le gel des prix arrive
après les augmentations voilà ce qu'il
faut au
moins un chèque énergie dont tout le
monde convient qu'il ne correspond pas
du tout aux montants qui va être
finalement associée à ces hausses de
factures voilà alors pendant sur la
relance et la croissance vous ils vous y
croyez aussi croyez vous n'y croyez pas
c'est quelque chose qui est susceptible
de créer aussi peut-être une dynamique
et d'améliorer la situation de
l'ensemble de la société je crois comme
tous les économistes que quand vous
fermez un robinet comme ça a été fait
l'année dernière au moment du
confinement et que vous leur ouvrait
mécaniquement vous avez une situation de
croissance mais vous pouvez convenir
avec moi que cette situation croissance
loin parle de 6% ça correspond pas à une
situation de croissance que vous avez en
période normale c'est en quelque sorte
une croissance qui est due à l'ampleur
de la chute que nous avions eue avant
non moins intéressante elle sera
éphémère pour vous et puis ce que je
vois surtout elle ne fait que compenser
ou à peine ce qui a été perdu bien sûr
et ce que je vois surtout c'est que la
crise que nous vivons de l'aco vide est
aussi une injonction à changer les
choses en profondeur
nous ce que nous proposons aujourd'hui
pour l'économie de ce pays c'est de la
mettre entièrement au service du grand
défi qui nous fait face dont on parle
trop peu qu'est la crise climatique on
le sait d'ici à 2100 le giec nous là
nous l'a dit cet été c'est plus 2,7
degrés et on sait ce que produit déjà un
degré de réchauffement climatique voyez
par exemple les images de marseille où
tout le monde découvre que le changement
climatique en bords de la méditerranée
c'est d'abord beaucoup de flotte qui
tombent partout et donc une mobilisation
générale qui est nécessaire ce que nous
voulons faire c'est mettre toute
l'économie de ce pays au service de du
fait de relever le défi du changement
climatique ça veut dire planifier la
bifurcation écologique de notre économie
la transition énergétique la transition
de notre modèle agricole les transports
le plan merde tout ça c'est beaucoup
d'emplois
aujourd'hui vous attendez une
mobilisation syndicale très forte vous
pensez qu'il aura beaucoup de monde dans
la rue c'est le début de quelque chose
ou pas écoutez moi ce que j'observe
c'est que l'on ait fait les choix qui
sont faits de manifestations syndicales
le mardi après en une forme d'assurance
et c'est assez compliqué on va dire les
choses franchement moi je suis pas
responsable syndical mais je vois une
chose c'est qu'il ya plus de
mobilisation quand on permet aux gens de
venir s'associer à un mouvement en
dehors des périodes de travail par
exemple ils ont fait un mauvais choix
donc je ne sais pas aujourd'hui qu'on va
tirer sur l'ambulance moi j'appelle tout
le monde à y être parce que il faut
redire que cette réforme de l'assurance
chômage et injuste violente que d'autres
solutions existent y compris pour
relancer l'emploi dans ce pays pardon de
vous dire que partager le temps de
travail comme nous le proposons diminuer
le temps de travail hebdomadaire avoir
la retraite à 60 ans sans parler de la
et aussi créer de l'activité de l'emploi
on va parler de la réforme des retraites
puisqu'il a fini par un petit peu
relancé le dans une interview à
challenges la semaine dernière il dit
que ça doit être pour lui la première
réforme du prochain quinquennat et il
propose de reporter l'âge de départ
jusqu'à 65 66 67 ans je vais pas vous
demander si vous êtes favorable je crois
que tout le monde connaît la réponse
mais il dit que nous préférons continuer
à danser au dessus du volcan que de
prendre des mesures drastiques et
parfois amers à ce qu'il n'a pas raison
danser autour du volcan bon c'est ce
sont des des ces démos de sorciers du
fric ça en réalité moi je vais vous dire
une chose un sorcier du fric mais bien
sûr j'ai 67 ans et pourquoi pas 77
pendant qu'on y est ce que vous savez à
combien à quel âge est aujourd'hui
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé en
france c'est 62 ans et cette espérance
de vie en bonne santé elle recule alors
petit cours pour toutes celles et ceux
qui à chaque fois que monsieur philippe
sort ce genre de phrases ou monsieur
demers au monsieur macron regardent
leurs chaussures en disant ah oui
évidemment ces gens là en raison on vit
plus longtemps il va falloir travailler
plus longtemps après tout c'est logique
n'est ce pas non pas du tout pourquoi
d'abord parce que on vit d'autant plus
longtemps que le temps de travail a
diminué bien évidemment il ya aussi le
progrès de la médecine et tout le reste
mais à mesure que le temps de travail a
diminué dans la vie dans la semaine
l'espérance de vie a aussi augmenté
première chose ensuite il ya une
négation absolue du fait que par exemple
entre un cadre et un ouvrier vous avez
six années d'écart d'espérance de vie
entre les 5% les plus riches et les 5 %
les plus pauvres c'est très années
d'écart d'espérance de vie le
gouvernement dit qu'il faut tenir compte
de la pénibilité bien évidemment elles
tendent qui commence par dire qu'on a un
problème de financement des retraites et
moi je veux rassurer tout le monde à les
y respirer un bon coup non il n'y a pas
de problème de financement des retraites
imminent d'autant plus que dans les
fonds de réserve qui ont été constitués
pour ça il ya 150 milliards d'euros dont
quel temps de voir venir premièrement
ensuite puisque la part des seniors dans
la population augmente c'est vrai il
faut faire ce qu'on a toujours fait
jusque-là consacrer une part plus
importante de notre produit intérieur
brut une part plus importante de la
richesse aux retraites sauf que en dix
ans comme monsieur philippe faut
travailler plus longtemps à près de 14%
l'air mais les justement mal à tirer
simplement écouter pour financer pour
financer la retraite à 60 ans que nous
proposons il faut aller tranquillement
vers 2% de plus de la richesse nationale
et jusqu'à 16% mais c'est indolore si
vous augmentez les salaires si vous
créer de l'activité et de l'emploi comme
je viens parler mais vous pouvez
augmenter la proportion les cotisations
en quelque sorte c'est dire puisqu'il ya
plus de monde autour de la table il faut
juste cuisine et un plus gros gâteau pas
dire aux gens on va faire des trucs
toujours plus petite part et puis songer
au fait qu augmenter l'âge de départ à
la retraite mais s'est aussi aggravé le
chômage aux deux extrémités de la vie
active d'un côté le chômage des seniors
dont vous savez très bien qu'à plus de
55 ans ils ont du mal à retrouver un
emploi et de l'autre le chômage des
jeunes qui peinent à s'insérer dans la
vie active donc écouter à toutes celles
et ceux qui finalement se laisser
atteindre par cette logique selon
laquelle inéluctablement il faudrait
travailler plus longtemps non ça n'est
pas vrai non si on partage la richesse
produite on peut faire la retraite à 60
ans avec aucune pension inférieure au
smic pour une carrière complète le tout
c'est partager les richesses et les
gentils monsieur comme edouard philippe
qui vous racontent faut travailler plus
longtemps sont ceux qui précisément ne
veulent pas partager la richesse
produite un mot dans un registre tout à
fait différent le pass sanitaire jusque
jusque jusqu'à l'été par exemple vous
êtes vous êtes pour vous être contre
écoutez moi je suis strictement opposée
au pass sanitaires depuis le début et
d'ailleurs si vous voulez des arguments
contre l'extension du pass sanitaire le
mieux que vous ayez à faire c'est
d'écouter monsieur macro lui-même ou
monsieur vers en avant qu'ils aient
décidé l'extension du pass sanitaires
car quelques jours avant le 12 juillet
c'est monsieur véran qui nous faisait de
formidable plaidoyer pour nous expliquer
combien il serait intolérable qu en
france on est à présenter des données de
santé pour rentrer dans des lieux de la
vie quotidienne comme le café le théâtre
ou lors ce dispositif auquel vous contre
lequel vous êtes opposé est-ce qu'il
peut être contrôlé par le parlement et
comment va écouter pour l'instant on
voit bien comment ça se passe c'est à
dire qu'à chaque chose que le à chaque
fois que le parlement est sollicité
c'est après les allocutions télévisuelle
de monsieur macra moyen de changer cette
deuxième annonce et erika nicklas
d'études ça se passe toujours de la même
manière et on ne cesse de se battre et y
compris on leur a fait beaucoup de
propositions veut dire soyons sérieux
bien évidemment nous sommes dans notre
rôle d'opposant mais dans une situation
comme celle de la crise sanitaire que
nous avons connu la manière dont nous
avons agi avec le groupe france en
soumise à l'assemblée consiste à se dire
si nous avions été à leur place
qu'aurions nous fait on leur a fait des
kilos de propositions jusqu'au mois de
novembre dernier 1 1 un document complet
un plan d'alternative au confinement
pourquoi nous sommes opposés au pass
sanitaire parce que le passé ni terre
confère une illusion d'immunité nous
sommes favorables à la vaccination mais
selon la ligne qui est finalement celle
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
c'est à dire la conviction et vous voyez
que des pays comme l'espagne ont réussi
avec ciné 100 % des personnes fragiles
sans avoir ni d'obligations ni de passes
sanitaires et surtout le pass sanitaire
exonère le gouvernement de faire tout ce
qu'ils auraient à faire par ailleurs
pourquoi alors que la rentrée des
classes est passé nous n'avons toujours
pas nos salles de classe équipées de
purificateurs d'air comme ça se fait
ailleurs on termine par un peu de
politique ou est-ce que vous en êtes ce
que vous discutez avec vos partenaires à
gauche où chacun part dans son coin
c'est fini écoutez on a beaucoup discuté
beaucoup dans plus posé non mais
attendez évidemment qu'il reste six mois
avant l'échéance j'ai bon espoir que des
choses bougent encore mais vous au nom
du parti afin de lui du mouvement vous
parlez avec qui aujourd'hui mais on
parle avec tout le monde sans aucune
difficulté mais si vous voulez donc
c'est encore possible de se
croiser les gens on discute avec tout le
monde ce que je veux dire c'est que
regardez-vous politique de des
présidentielles williams était au pardon
on parle aussi de présidentielle mais
écoutez soyons sérieux on n'a aucune
difficulté en discuter mais ne vous at
on pas dit quand nous sommes partis en
campagne au mois de novembre que tout le
monde voudrait avoir son candidat et
vous souvenez des petites réunions de
danse du ventre bras dessus bras dessous
de monsieur jadot et monsieur faure qui
misait super on va avoir un candidat
commun nous avons dit que tout ça était
une comédie la preuve ça n'est même plus
à leur ordre du jour en revanche que
nous disons c'est que oui peut-être des
dispersions inutile qu'on peut éviter
moi par exemple je m'interroge toujours
pour savoir pourquoi ce qui a été
possible avec le parti communiste
français en 2012 et en 2017 ne le serait
pas en 2022 et des dispersions qu'on
doit pouvoir éviter pour
évidemment la question qui est posée
aujourd'hui ce qu'il sera bien sûr
évidemment et heureusement mais j'espère
que qu'ils m'entendent c'est à dire que
la question qui est posée joly c'est de
savoir si c'est le bloc populaire pour
une politique de rupture qui gardent la
main dans cet espace politique ou si
c'est un centre gauche leur verdict a
par ailleurs déjà gouverné ce pays et
dont les français se souviennent qui
prend la main et puis surtout dire une
chose c'est qu'en 2022 il s'agit de
l'emporter enfin moi je le dis très
sincèrement nous n'avons pas renoncé à
cette idée et je crois que parmi les
entraîneurs au cutter vous allez faire
avec autant de quantité le problème ce
n'est pas le nombre de candidats il peut
d'abord accéder au sol peut en avoir 15
20 25 le problème c'est pas qui est trop
de candidats le problème c'est que les
électeurs eux par contre sache se
regrouper ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans
l'est la plupart des enquêtes d'opinion
c'est que jean luc mélenchon est bien en
avant cet espace politique et y compris
si le ticket d'entrée au second tour ça
baisse comme on le voit à la faveur de
quelques événements imprévus alors le
second tour est accessible donc moi je
dis dès maintenant aux électeurs qu'ils
m'entendent certes il ya beaucoup de
candidats mais regroupez-vous autour du
vote efficace pour changer nos
institutions pour partager les richesses
pour faire la planification écologique
on a vu dans un sondage récent que jean
luc mélenchon était à quelques doigts du
second tour donc il faut se regrouper
dès à présent un mois j'ai besoin d'un
toutefois parrainage écoutez ça avance
mais je ne vous cache pas que c'est
toujours très laborieux c'est à dire
sans le parti et c'est dire que pour une
formation politique comme la nôtre qui
n'est pas un parti d'élus structure et
de longue date c'est comme à chaque fois
le bâton de pèlerin et la chasse aux
parrainages à l'heure où je vous parle
on est les amarres oui je pense qu'on
les aura parce que le travail est
sérieusement fait parce qu'il faut
saluer tous les maires de ces communes
qui en quelque sorte en dépit de leur
étiquette politique ont à coeur de faire
vivre la démocratie mais à l'heure qu'il
est on est à peu près en passe
d'atteindre la moitié du chemin 250 à la
csac presque et pendant alors pendant
que ces tractations ces calculs continue
enfin vous chacun mène sa barque on
n'avait pas l'impression qu'eric zemmour
impose ses thèmes de campagne évidemment
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs nous avons souhaité que jean
luc mélenchon débattre face à lui parce
que monsieur zemmour dont certains ont
toutes sortes de pudeur en disant non il
faut pas lui donner trop d'importance
mais avant même ce débat il avait les
unes de quotidiens nationaux
les matinales politique ils recherchent
des parrainages et des financements donc
monsieur zemmour il agit même s'il n'est
pas encore déclaré candidat il agit en
candidat il a fait une percée dans les
sondages et dès lors
d'ébats ce n'est pas le débat qui lui a
fait de la publicité au contraire dans
ce débat nous avons eu ce qui est
nécessaire et utile de la confrontation
d'idées entre deux idées de la france
une vision ethniciste que porte monsieur
zemmour et une vision profondément
républicaine celle qui consiste à dire
nous avons de grands défis et nous
allons y faire face en faisant france de
tout bois le contrat qui nous lie c'est
liberté égalité fraternité pas une
religion une couleur de peau ou une
vision de la civilisation kaka monsieur
zemmour donc je crois qu'il fallait
cette confrontation de dire que nous
sommes adversaires résolus de l'extrême
droite et puis il faut prendre les gens
à témoin dire que monsieur zemmour
madame le pen ont une fonction dans la
période comme toutes celles des sports
mais évidemment le dire quand vous
regardez toutes les déclarations de
monsieur zemmour les manipulations
historiques etc évidemment que c'est
l'extrême droite et que derrière
d'ailleurs monsieur zemmour on le voit
encore ce week end à lille vous avez eu
en marge de sa venue des violences qui
ont été réalisés donc évidemment qu'il
faut la combattre pied-à-pied est juste
d'un mot dire une chose tout cela
procède d'une grande diversion parce que
les français ont des causes communes on
a parlé du pouvoir d'achat on a parlé
des salaires de l'emploi de la question
climatique et pendant ce temps vous avez
monsieur zemmour madame le pen en idiots
utiles du système qui viennent en style
et la division pour faire croire que le
vrai problème c'est l'immigration la
couleur de peau de votre voisin où tout
le reste franchement regardez leurs
déclarations sur l'économie ils sont
finalement très macro nist monsieur
zemmour propose le report de l'âge légal
de la retraite et madame le pen ne veut
pas augmenter vos salaires bon bah voilà
je pense que le choix est vite fait que
vous seriez retraite mahina peinait sur
la traite à 60 ans écoutez si elle
reprend des idées ne pas on va pas on va
pas dire le contraire mais en tout cas
j'ai pas vu que sur les salaires elle
proposait une augmentation or pour nous
c'est clair c'est le smic 1400 euros
nets merci beaucoup merci à notre invité
ce matin
[Musique]